this is what's weird is most people
think Frankenstein is the monster it's
not the monster
it's the Victor Frankenstein is the
creator of Frankenstein I mean you know
who's the monster called Chacko which is
interesting yeah
so Victor Frankenstein looked down at
his creation in the monster looked up at
him and said master creator and
Frankenstein thought to himself he has
white eyes and black lips and yellow
skin and arteries bursting out of his
skin Vince is not that person I thought
I would be greeting and he ran out of
the room run run run run run run
and he hid in his bedroom and he thought
to himself this is terrible what I've
done
Oh what do I do he laid down and went to
sleep
the monster was staring right down felt
a big bang
it's so frank enstein said Frankenstein
Frankenstein did I say that
yeah okay that's how scary it is you
don't want to say it the same so what
I'm trying to say is Victor Frankenstein
freaked out so bad no please don't
please
I want nothing to do with you and the
monster goes listen to this cuz this is
scary you need to create a companion for
me or I will kill your lover dr.
Frankenstein made the bride but then all
of a sudden had second feelings about
this because what if she became a freak
whoa what would he do how much guilt
would he feel so he destroyed
Frankenstein's bride and just stopped
but sure enough Frankenstein rushed into
the bedroom and said what it's going on
the monster killed the fiancee wife and
there she was dead and the monster said
you have destroyed my love life because
you destroyed my sexpot
you know like in that day it would have
been a sex bomb like a real doll yeah
like a baa-baa a doll and he ran out of
the room and was never
to be seen again until later now is the
story up to now so Mary said how did I
do I believe that I have done quite a
scary story have I not Lord Byron and
Shelley after the story we're silent and
then all of a sudden everybody was like
oh my god I'm pissing out of my balls
this is so amazing and Mary looked at
that and said really
are you serious and Percy said to Mary
you have got to write this down and sell
it what what what what what what
[Laughter]
[Music]
you